what's going on a reject nation Greg
Alba here and I'm John Humphrey so we
did our non-spoiler review of bright and
I keep emphasizing how I feel like I
have to give spoilers to explain my
reasoning for issues with the film
so just PD issues essentially what I'm
going to talk about here the next Landis
that's my biggest issue is that pervert
sorry I just learned a lot of things so
overall if you guys didn't catch our
non-spoiler John and I both enjoyed it
you probably get a three and a half I
give it like a four I think the world is
really cool I think Will Smith and Joel
Edgerton are really cool and I think
there's a lot of great things in this
movie the issues that I have really come
in the last half of this film and that's
when the film gets a little bit bigger
than it needs to be I kept fearing when
I was watching it because I know this is
David Ayer and I was like oh my god is
this gonna go down Suicide Squad
enchantra's territory doesn't fully go
there but it goes there just enough for
me to have issue with it it doesn't go
full off the rails like Suicide Squad
but it does flirt with that line of yeah
too much and some of that kind of takes
away from the more original elements
that make the first part of this movie
so much fun exactly for starters the elf
storyline with because the elf sort of
line is fine to me and I like the
inclusion of the elves I like how
they're written to be these like kind of
scary the enemies of the movie I feel
like that could have been more subtle
with the bigger aspects of it with the
wand and the magic yeah and the prophecy
all those things I felt would have been
better as subtle undertones as opposed
to a lot of exposition and more
exploration than necessary for this film
because you have this one story line
within the feds where there's like the
elf who's kind of like an anime
character and his partner who's a human
they kind of investigate any and all
magical disturbances yeah that are above
the regular police's pay grade and the
storyline that gets introduced a lot
through that aspect and then eventually
ties in with Will Smith in joel edgerton
is
the storyline of the Dark Lord is
returning and he wants to conquer the
world and take back what's his and you
could have done that a little bit more
subtly you didn't have to make it such a
big prominent part of the entirety of
the film by the time the story wraps up
I realize those characters they are so
honest enchi Lister a purpose because
the information they learn eventually
will smith and joel edgerton learn the
same piece of information outside of
those guys and it just went really
sideways from that point they have this
elf they're protecting who has a want
who gives them all the information that
this other storyline learns and then by
the time wil smith and joel edgerton are
being held captive by the feds they
don't even have a scene that's worthy of
having them there there's nothing
revealed in that scene other than yeah
they're gonna cover it up yeah I wish
those characters had gotten more time or
something to make that beep lot more
engaging and more in line with the rest
of the movie because after a while it
starts to feel like this afterthought
and part way through the movie
especially my complaints of the dialogue
come in with those characters absolutely
absolutely
cuz the idea of the world-building
aspect of it is really cool like oh the
feds have this department that hunts
down magic people that's a cool element
to infuse into this movie and it makes
sense however it doesn't really serve
this story ultimately now but my biggest
issue is honestly the whole finale of
the film Noomi Rapace no mera pause
she's a good actress and she plays her
her role well but that's when I guess
way too in-depth of the whole Dark Lord
stuff when her character dies at the end
of the film because Will Smith picks up
the wand reveals he's a bright and then
kills her that was like too much too
much
well like it no I they handled it too
because partly they telegraphed that so
early on that I was like oh I know
exactly what's gonna happen and I just
don't know when and and it's a legacy
movie I was wishing they wouldn't do it
I was wishing that Will Smith would not
be a bright for me that ruins a lot of
what makes that
are so cool what makes the the story so
cool of just a regular org and a regular
human for put in this mission bigger
than themselves
and then to find out that okay okay you
could have your prophecy elements and
put it towards the elf or if anything
make your bright reveal be the Oracle
joel edgerton is character it makes more
sense for the story to go that path it
aligns it better with the Nick character
for everything this guy's had to put up
with his whole life fingers and the fact
that he's the one who believes in
prophecies and everything it would have
made more sense for me for it to have
been Nick and it would have been more
rewarding too we might be in a prophecy
we're not in a prophecy for me Will
Smith being the bright is more like was
this Will Smith's decision and then he
go to David Ayer was like you know I got
to be the bride right see I don't think
that that's ultimately a bad way to go
because if you think at least for me I
thought maybe having joel edgerton be
the orc and now Will Smith is a special
thing too I don't love the whole just
trend of chosen ones but basically I
didn't think this movie earned it very
well now it's like it's one of those
things where at the last minute we're
gonna do that thing that we've
established is chancy but you know it's
gonna work out okay it's like I can see
why if joel edgerton was the bright well
then why does he need Will Smith because
now he's to magic things at the same
time and so I'm like making Will Smith
special too does give them a bond I just
wish that the movie had maybe nixed the
subplot with the feds and given more
time to that or something or did it in a
different manner because having him just
be like screw it I'm gonna pick it up
knowing full well that the chances are
slim and I might explode like yeah it
just feels so movie what I felt like
there wasn't really an even though it's
telegraphed early I also felt like it
wasn't built up well for him to be the
bright because the idea of prophecy and
all that comes in rather late into the
film so at a time the Servilia he's the
bright it feels like a very convenient
plot point for him to kill off the main
villain of the movie that's what I read
to me as well you know this is
convenient yeah this is what they need
to solve it and and the villains too
meant like the second she got to speak I
like that character so much more
coz the villains nobody ever pass and
her little team mates yeah they like
barely speak and then after a while they
do become just like oh yeah there's just
the villains we have to run away from
until yeah you know Will Smith figures
this thing out and it does falter a bit
when it comes to the the handling of the
magic one I think it's a good idea I do
think it's a cool nifty place to take
this and they said like this thing with
the power of a nuclear weapon yeah no
that's like intriguing but I don't think
the movie handled that I don't think any
of them needed to be the bright I don't
think Joel Edgerton or Will Smith needed
to be the bright I think it would
another I think it would have been way
more special that way because need to
tikka yeah yeah just make it make it
tick make make wanna be Harley Quinn
yeah is the first half up until she
started talking I really was like why is
there a whole design keep reminding me
of Harley Quinn
yeah the flips the acrobats even the
clothing in a way reminded me a lot of
Harley Quinn and specifically Suicide
Squad Harley Quinn and I was definitely
distracting but it would have been more
special if you just had her be it
because we made the characters so
special watching the whole times that
they're just two regular cops yeah and
it would be so intriguing to have an orc
a bright and and a street smart savvy
human because in that context you know
Will Smith is their ambassador to the
world yeah and that could make something
more intriguing than just what starts
off being a fun imaginative sort of
original idea that kind of sells out to
the the same beats you're used to
because well Will Smith's character has
issues with having the orc as his
partner he doesn't hate orcs as a whole
he doesn't he's not racist but there are
problems that are coming from him having
him as a partner and he doesn't trust
him because of an incident that happened
so that all makes sense but we also like
Will Smith because of the fact that he's
not like the rest of the cops who are
like screw orcs yada yada yada he's not
a bad dude he's not he's not a bad dude
and then the fact that you make him a
bright takes away some of that effect of
him being that good human now yeah I
don't know
I don't have major issues with hippie of
right now major issues that yeah it's
like in an intermittent way it's kind of
satisfying to watch at the exact moment
but the more I think about it I'm like
ah this could have been so much more
successful to me because I did have a
surprisingly good time watching it but
the more I think about it the more I
wish that they had kept to the main
conflict as the internal affairs thing
and then brought the magic wand in and
and and dressed that in a different like
keep it in the real world like the
internal affairs thing in the
relationship that was the powerhouse of
the movie yeah all this stuff for like
Dark Lord and everything like that you
know that's the wording stuff that's the
stuff is way bigger than the interesting
like do your tolerance metaphor and
let's do all the levels of the police
hierarchy instead of pulling the
parachute halfway through and and
leading to this big showdown which is a
good moment which is you know kind of an
intense moment when he's talking to him
outside right before the four cops come
out - yeah - screw the both of them you
know I wish this movie had stayed closer
to the ground like I said in the other
yeah
and not gotten so distracted by cramming
all the fantasy stuff in right now
because especially they greenlit the
sequel the day before this came out so
they must have had faith in it and I
sort of wish they didn't throw
everything at the first movie I guess
yeah that's true and I also I'm not a
big fan of sequel setups that are so
like that's what the feds felt like
that's what the Will Smith being a bride
felt like it all felt like sequel set up
territory for me
yeah well I'm like just tell the one
grounded story you guys had that was
great cuz everything's better when
they're doing that yeah even the dial
like the dialogue is much better when
they're doing yeah and the situation's
feel legit intense yeah there's I was
surprised that was one of the nicer
surprises about this for me as a number
of those scenes I was like oh man I mean
overall I would still say it's a really
good movie I don't agree with it being
just an OK film granted the flaws I feel
very strongly about but without those
flaws I still got a good like 80% of
this movie at least that is really
strong to me so yeah that's just the
spoiler territory we wanted to cover did
you guys see bright did you like it the
bright light up there
life you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification Bell
make sure to follow us on patreon
patreon comm slash the real rejects it's
like a second youtube channel over there
people having a lot of fun and also what
do you hope the bright sequel explores
next time they go to New York ah New
York cops yeah and the next one Rome
time we had one more kind of magic yeah
eventually everyone's nice vampires and
werewolves Frankenstein monsters and
creatures from the black and white are
looming there's even more